welcome to the program it is stunning
how the news is just non-stop the last
48 hours just breaking story after
breaking story and at the top of the
list at least among other stories is
this revelation from acting FBI director
Andrew McCabe that the FBI investigation
into Trump Russia collusion is going to
continue and that the FBI will not be
keeping the White House informed as to
the progress of that which if you're
Donald Trump and you made this haphazard
move to fire FBI director James Comey
last week apparently by any reasonable
analysis to attempt to interrupt the
Trump Russia investigation you've got to
be losing your you-know-what in the Oval
Office and we'll get to that a little
bit James Comey of course fired
FBI director fired last week by
President Donald Trump the reason that
was given the mishandling of the Hillary
Clinton email investigation completely
unbelievable I don't know anybody other
than the most extreme committed
ideologues or Trumpets that believe that
explanation Comey replaced by Andrew
McCabe as acting head of the FBI Comey
was going to testify last Thursday that
didn't happen because of the firing so
we immediately asked the question what
does this firing do to the progress or
to the path forward of the FBI's Trump
Russia investigation because clearly it
immediately had the impact of changing
James Comey status as the FBI director
who's about to testify to the former FBI
director who is no longer going to
testify we did learn that James Comey
may still testify as a private citizen
he's been asked to testify and we'll see
if that ultimately happens but a major
question was what happens to the
investigation and the answer is
according to the head of the FBI the
acting head of the FBI Andrew McCabe the
agency will continue to investigate
alleged links between Russia and Donald
Trump's campaign but they will not
routinely update the White House about
the progress of that investing
and to to that my reaction is number one
great and number two why was the FBI
regularly updating the White House about
the progress of that investigation when
the White House was the entity being
investigated so that's a major concern
and that's not being discussed nearly as
much as I expected it's been 72 hours
since this news broke at this point and
the obvious question to me is why would
you update the investigation this is why
was your update the White House about
this investigation this is one of the
critique criticisms that was made of of
a Devin Nunez the Republican congressman
who was running the House Intelligence
House investigation into Trump Russia
why was he criticized for running to the
White House to talk about what they had
but nobody is saying hey wait Andrew
you're saying you're no longer going to
update the White House about the
investigation why were you ever updating
the White House about the investigation
so in any case Andrew McCabe saying that
the firing of James Comey is not going
to impact the investigation at all and
the the one of the more interesting
things from Andrew McCabe's testimony
was to defend the firing of James Comey
the White House said that the 56 year
old FBI director had lost the confidence
of the majority of the sort of
rank-and-file members of the FBI Andrew
McCabe said yeah no that completely
rejected completely rejected that notion
saying the FBI rank and file like James
Comey and had the full confidence they
had full confidence in James Comey so
that talking point absolutely destroyed
we had another talking point within
hours of president Trump's firing of
James Comey last week we had White House
deputy press secretary Sarah Huckabee
sanders say that James Comey had
committed quote atrocities during the
investigation into Trump Russia
that's absolutely bogus Andrew McCabe
destroy
the White House talking points on that
as well emphasizing that James Comey was
very well liked in terms of how he was
handling the investigation and that that
investigation would continue any day now
are we going to hear that Donald Trump
has lost confidence in Andrew McCabe
which is of course a predecessor to
firing can you just imagine for a second
the temper tantrum that must be
happening at the White House did Donald
Trump really think that firing James
Comey was going to make the entire Trump
Russia investigation go away I'm
increasingly convinced that Trump's
latest actions on this have if anything
accelerated the entire Trump Russia
thing rather than stonewalling it which
is probably what Donald Trump sought to
do meanwhile Russians were hanging out
in the Oval Office Russian media covered
it American media not allowed in I'll
tell you more about that later but
everything just everything falling apart
on this for Donald Trump